Disqus we're all here together here's a
new concept that I'm instilling on a
Friday it's called one take Friday why
is it called one take Friday because
sometimes you shoot a bunch of footage
all day long on a really giant subtle
cool ish camera thinking you're gonna do
a day-in-the-life vlog when you get home
at night and then you have a great day
and you capture all these clips and then
you get home and you realize that this
goddamn camera won't import the clips
into your computer so basically the
whole Kendra is overcompensating for the
simplicity you should have to upload to
a computer so all the fun that I had
today is all locked inside this camera
good now I know what it's like to be a
corny dude around a girl look [ __ ]
chastity belt tell me my movie nights
late and I need to post my video for
tomorrow and I've been spending a long
time trying to figure out how to get all
my fun Clips off of this camera so long
in fact they're not that fun to me
anymore so I decided that what I'm just
gonna talk to you unedited terrifying
right I wouldn't on my tumblr and ask
you guys for suggestions on things to
talk about so let's see what you've said
eat a cookie I've already eaten my
feelings so I'm okay on that front how
to be successful how to be successful
non social media you are asking the
wrong person
that question he driving lessons also
asking the wrong person if I could
upload the clips from this for today you
would know exactly why
inside joke with myself in this [ __ ]
piece of beautiful [ __ ] why do all the
things that suck look so beautiful on
the outside life lesson huh tell me what
to do after college make a collage that
could be a fun time I mean it would take
up at least minutes upon minutes of time
from you thinking about like what you
should be doing with your life after
college excuse me tell us about you in
college um in college I was I was myself
I had my own legal name I was very a
relatively introverted and I was so
focused on work I worked way too hard
the my one regret about college is not
socializing as much or at least not
balancing the social and work stuff that
I did because I literally one semester
worked at an Applebee's and then also
worked teaching tennis all around the
county that I went to college in on the
days that I head off so like there was
never a night that I wasn't working I'm
a fun time let's see make a video where
we can ship booze and beans
if goos and beans ever got together it'd
be goose eating beans do you know what
geese is
Jace's gooses Oh God my vocabulary has
never been great but beans his name as
beans because these is edible and goose
is the carnivore like all true geese
never trust a goose words to live by
slugs
slugs are just like the lazier older
brother of snails right
I mean snails get turned into escargot
which in France is like a delicacy
whereas slugs everyone's like Oh gross
what Wow Oh
slimy but snails have ones like oh
that's what butter on them they are
divine yes the slugs are just kind of
like they're the people that didn't
figure out what to do after college how
to give a good nickname a good nickname
is half based in truth and half based in
like total ridiculousness that is
somewhat um either degrading or like
irritating for the person who gets it
nickname so like goose I call her like
am a a let's see beautiful [ __ ] Factory
yeah fight for open - in small
conservative communities not going to
touch that one - dress Goosen your
clothes look I really want to meet Sarah
McLachlan one day but I don't want to
meet her on those terms okay
lamps can't spell lamps without maps
I'll try not to die but I say to myself
every morning when I wake up play truth
or dare with goose here we go goose
truth or dare truth do you really want
to be playing this game no okay
we nailed it you should call Monday's my
mind
Monday's thoughts are things the secret
cetera get a real job
is this her life do we all exist is this
just an illusion
are you lucid dreaming and no one's
telling you am I here right now are you
watching this right now does this matter
do you matter why do you matter but why
do you matter okay but why okay but why
and then ultimately why this is what
happens when technology doesn't work I
don't know